did not grow up thinking I was going to
be a chef that was never the plan but I
have always been the kind of person who
needs to like shove it in people's faces
and be like huh look what I can do but
in a really nice way
meet kathleena she's on a mission to
make delicious food for every allergy
and intolerance but with severe food
allergies herself she rarely tastes the
food she makes she's even allergic to
flowers
I mean I generally eat once a day to try
to minimize the amount of reactions that
there could be
my reactions can range from you know
what one might consider mild so headache
irritations all over your body to severe
anaphylaxis near death I cook by sight I
cook by sound I cook by smell I cook by
really the science of it all I love
making food that shouldn't exist and
when it does it knocks you off your feet
and you go wait you made this and you
can't eat it and I'm like yeah what's it
taste like tell me all about it
for katholina to cook certain foods
safely she wears a respirator I think
I've had to wear my respirator for about
seven or eight years now
I make it look cool and look good but
it's really uncomfortable it's like
having a death grip on your face and
then sometimes when you're cooking it
fogs up so like you can't really see
what you're doing you're like literally
like windshield wiping your own face
it's really weird going to the shops can
set off her allergies too but a chef
always needs ingredients so when you're
at the grocery store corn is everywhere
right the wax on produce is corn derived
even like the adhesive on the stickers
that they use usually corn derived it's
in so many places that you literally
cannot avoid it unless you buy a piece
of land and never leave
after acing her Chef training and
rewriting her French pastry exam to be
top nine free kathleena launched race a
platform to teach cooking for restricted
diets
there's like all
think can't exist because oh you can't
have this that's free from gluten dairy
egg peanut blah blah blah all the things
and I'm like yeah watch me you know if
you're vegan they're like oh and here's
some wheat and some tree nuts and some
soy and they throw every allergen into
almost every recipe and it's I'm like
wait what about people who are allergic
to these things or can't have this or
can't have that right I will find all of
these strange ways to bring back flavor
and texture and experience when you
thought you'd never have it again it
includes the entire community no one
gets left behind
one of the coolest kicks I ever made
it's dubbed candy overload cake a mom
called and she said my daughter's
turning 12 but because of her allergies
the kid had just never had a birthday
cake and I said okay well how about
since it's her first cake and you know
me go big or go home cookies candies
chocolates anything that's safe
marshmallows all of it just all goes on
top the dad brings the little girl to
pick up her cake and I just slide it
over and I'm like happy birthday and dad
is on the verge of tears her face was
just so like
that that's mine you know like you never
forget that moment like helping kids
have that first something that everybody
takes for granted
like it's not about being a chef it's
about Reinventing the world for people
who cannot engage in it just because you
have this wild Fringe diagnosis does not
mean you can't live
you're going to live
you just gotta put in some elbow grease
a lot of it actually
our store is Live use the link in the
caption to grab your great big story
merch and don't forget to like subscribe
and leave a comment thanks bye